a seis versos uno cita con chicos basado
en sus atuendos ar tendrá una cita con
seis chicos elegir a uno según su
atuendo y personalidad me llamo art
tengo 29 años y soy un estudiante de
tiempo completo trabajo en un bar y soy
tutor de matemáticas estoy listo para
ver unos buenos zapatos
muy bien
definitivamente siento diferentes vibras
por aquí me gusta el primero me gustan
sus botas negras creo que esos son el
segundo tiene unas buenas plataformas
hazme una pequeña demostración estos se
ven un poco más atléticos verdad tal vez
un poco de estilo muy bien estos son tus
favoritos o si han estado conmigo en
algunos años hay algunas historias
detrás de eso no tiene una actitud
entiendo genial me gusta eso también me
gustan estos me gustan los colores y
luego estos últimos vaya estaba bajo
influencia cuando compre estos zapatos
confía en tuyo borrar tomado mejores
decisiones así que estando concursante
número uno si participarán en un
programa de competencia de televisión y
fueras a ganar qué programa sería y por
qué buena pregunta
totalmente nail'd dónde tienes que hacer
el peor trabajo de horneado posible me
agrada mucho divertir ya me gusta eso
concursante número dos fornicar boda o
matar a la roca barrio hasta ellos y
break band rock bien no conozco a
breitman rock así que tendré que
matarlos bien no sé si es sexy o no así
que podría ayudarnos muy tarde tendría
sexo con la rosca muy bien ese hombre
grande concursante número 3 hola hola
cuál es tu programa malo de televisión
favorito probablemente sea de rial
housewives justo ahora estoy obsesionado
con south lake city sí como jane ya está
a punto de ir a la cárcel por estafar a
todos esos pobres viejos dio igual
concursante número 4 si tuviéramos que
ver una serie de televisión en nuestra
primera cita es decir maratón ya que
serie veríamos de netflix me gustó mucho
jean y georgia la vi como cinco veces le
recomiendo muy bien concursante número 5
quien estudiaba favorita de todos los
tiempos que me viene a la mente es
madonna bien buena elección concursante
número 6 tus tres artistas musicales
favoritos son mis tres favoritos de bien
en apuros sabes que supongo que harían a
grandes la número uno y en realidad está
de primera y spotify lo sabía muy
disgusto dios mío y luego rosalía la
conoces sí pero no sé mucho de su música
es una vibra latina de muy perra mal y
eso es algo que trato de encarnar casi
todos los días te escribo mi estilo como
si fuera un mafioso de vacaciones
bien eso es muy específico me da una
buena idea de cómo te ves
ronda 1 eliminación art debe eliminar a
un chico de la guitarra
bien voy a eliminar al concursante
número 2
no lo sé los hijos quiero ahora doy la
vuelta
[Risas]
qué lindo atuendo cómo te llamas soy jim
y me
lo siento me gustan tus herencias me
gustan sus ojos cielos gracias odio odio
esta parte desearía poder conocer a
todos un poco más pero
ronda dos pantalones
bien o vaya algunos no me los esperaba
veo algo más de estilo en el concursante
número 1 concursante número 2 qué
material es ese puedes tocarlo si
quieres es mínimo y en realidad cuero
sintético amamos a los animales miren
este bien holgado y holgado en realidad
la parte de abajo por sí sola no tiene
mucho sentido pero cuando lo ves
combinado con la parte de arriba tiene
más sentido no está bien este me está
dando vibras de papá o no estoy seguro
si es tu estética pero me gusta
concursante número 5 estamos sintiendo
tu energía nos gusta concursante número
1 si fueras travesti cuál sería tu
nombre o buena pregunta si es
necesariamente lo sería alguna vez pero
si lo fuera tomaría el nombre de mi
mejor amiga quién tiene nombre de reina
sería algo como chery ride o editorial
en
concursante número 2 sí señor cuál sería
tu lema de ama de casa o qué buena
pregunta te puse en apuros belleza
gracia y con cara de odiosa bajo no vaya
concursante el número 3 en qué
aplicaciones estás o maldición las usó
todas tengo que exponerme al mundo me
entiendes algunos chicos no están en una
aplicación y luego otros están en una
aplicación diferente así que yo quieres
verlos a todos sí déjenme pidiendo
concursante número 4 cuál fue tu peor
cita y por qué o nunca he tenido una
cita o en serio si alguna razón sólo que
la oportunidad nunca se presentó
entiendo número 5 donde iríamos en
nuestra primera acción pues yo trabajo
en un parque temático que no nombraré
así que creo que sería bueno ir allí
especialmente esperando en la fila para
las atracciones hay mucho tiempo para
hablar y conocerse bien me gusta no te
estoy sobornando sólo digo que tengo
beneficio
ronda 2 eliminación audio smart debe
eliminar a dos chicos de la cinta rápida
el primero que eliminar es el
concursante el número 4
hola mucho un placer cómo te llamas erik
eric un placer soy art art o si lindo
como su atuendo lo único que me preocupa
un poco es que él nunca ha estado en una
cita así que no sé si estoy listo para
esa experiencia y luego el próximo
concursante que voy a eliminar
el concursante número 3
igualmente como daniel yo soy a
complacer a moto gracias yo amo todo es
muchas gracias me siento como un idiota
pero es genial ver sus atuendos
ronda tres camisas
bien vaya concursante número uno no
esperaba eso
gracias también me gustan tus uñas me
encantas bien concursante número dos la
valla
me gusta la chaqueta me gustan los
accesorios también está tomando forma
bien gracias y el concursante número
tres hola me gusta este tatuaje te lo
agradezco me louis este año porque pensé
que el mundo se acabaría pero luego no
sucedió y ahora es tanto como ahora
tengo la misma pregunta para todos
comenzando por el número uno si tuviera
un día difícil como me consolaría bueno
primero necesitaría conocer tus
comodidades eres una chica netflix eres
una persona franca y directa
debemos correr al dispensario necesito
tener el porro y esto antes de que
llegue esta casa así que no lo sé
específicamente pero basándome en lo que
haría por un amigo o un extraño creo que
como dije te escucharía te sentaría e
intentaría que te alejes del panorama
general y también te recordaría todas
bendiciones que eres hermoso y que los
adorarás gracias ahora el número dos
para mí un buen ambiente es muy
importante así que creo que cuando
llegues a casa las luces deberían ser
tenue tal vez algunas velas me
aseguraría de que te encuentres en un
espacio hogareño escuchando tu música
favorita y probablemente yo ya esté
cocinando la cena así que sabes que
puedes prepararte para eso y sólo de
visitar hemos despertado te dejaría
desahogarte relajarte y despejar tu
mente me gusta número tres si llego a
casa después de un día difícil como me
consolar y us bueno primero sexo muy
caliente lo olvidaremos todo y nos
sentiremos bien todo bien y segundo
encontraremos quién te está haciendo
pasar un mal día y pincharemos sus
neumáticos me encanta bromeo lo haré yo
y tú le mentiras a la policía diciendo
que estuviste conmigo toda la noche que
protegerían sí sí yo haré trabajo sucio
no te preocupes por el jefe creo que
solo agregó más estrés a tu día con eso
los amo a todos por cierto lo lamento
am
eliminar al concursante número 2 los 200
[Risas]
hola amo tu cabello también gracias a un
placer conocerte cómo estás soy art y tú
soy rolling rolling da motus ar espera
ahora entiendo la referencia estábamos
hablando de eso
qué lindo lo siento mucho está
muy lindo me encantó su atuendo su
cabello y su energía está bien y luego
eliminar el número uno
lo siento pero estoy emocionado de verte
emocionado de verdad son los aretes todo
el mundo ha estado hablando de estos
malditos que me muero puedo abrazar
claro acabo de ponerme el refuerzo
genial
giorgio es un placer conocerte creo que
te gustará clima
dulces
revelación final
hola hola soy es un placer conocerte
llamando a un placer un abrazo si es por
supuesto
me encanta tu estilo y la serpiente la
vice ley como
viviendo ahora lista para pinchar
algunos neumáticos
los neumáticos yo también lo sigue
pensando y dije diablos la gente pensará
que fue una broma chicos no soy un
criminal no fue por diversión pensé en
que hablabas en cero es no pinchar en
neumáticos para conseguir una cita
bueno vayamos a pinchar algunos se
ingenian de llevaré al parque temático
de la ciudad divertido me encantaría
dios mío por eso es que no tengo citas
soy tan torpe frente a la gente estaba
mejor detrás de la cortina